all right and we are live
flashpoint ebon sis what is going on sir
oh you know sorry for the late Billy the
start everybody just had to tight a
couple things around the house but we
are here it's the last podcast of a year
for 2018 wrapping it up December
holidays are coming up just got some
craziness so probably not doing next
week and we all know it's probably gonna
be like nothing new coming so I figured
give you guys a little break from us as
well now you guys have put up with us
all year long it's been awesome but yeah
just kind of pretty cool a lot of
grinding going on and destiny whole
bunch of grinding especially if you
jumped into Izanami which I haven't even
touched yet I asked you if you guys
can't attach it I looked at like the the
quest chain and just that alone but no
it is there's definitely gonna be some
kind of going on this weekend but I'm
traveling a little bit on Sunday so it's
you know all tight squeeze but we'll see
what I can get done what about you min
bring grinding man I mean ever since the
Tuesday update the I've been noticing
the difference you know my quest to get
back to 600 on PC is I've been noticing
the difference in a primary and Gramps
as far as the drop level and the light
increase so it's been substantial I do
notice a difference some creeping my way
up to was about 580 right now about
Friday eighties I could be a little
higher but I just need some some cores
to get get some things up but a shout
out to scream shout out the car bye to
those guys been helping me out man so on
my quest to 600 very very cool so you
actually noticed a bump in the primes
have you seen the bump in the what am I
thinking of like director challenges and
stuff like that - I feel it more with
the primes it's still nice to see you
know the director stuff is cool but I
definitely see the difference it's like
almost 20 lights levels something like
plus a 20 but I've seen like like 15
excuse me light level increasing I'm
like wow this is a big job 15 from a
prime I think I sing it one time I was
like really big and I was just like it
could have been a thing that I was just
weakened in it you know it kind of gave
it to me but I've been noticing some
really bigger substantial jump so you
know it like I said only
out of time because now like okay now
I'm going through Kors a little bit just
to get some stuff up I'm trying not to
use them as much but uh yeah man I mean
I I definitely like this new update it
feels helpful and I'll trail hopefully
if I keep continuing my grind by the end
hopefully by the end of the weekend you
know by this weekend I should be rocking
and rolling maybe touch some 600 content
nice very cool yeah I was like even this
is a I kind of want to say it's like a
learning curve for Bungie but I was like
there's so many other games that could
have learned from they could have used
this process a little bit better I think
yeah
just because like yeah I mean the
everybody hits the wall everybody's all
disheartened it's like you just ease
that stuff a little better give the
people who aren't quite there that
quicker pace to be like I know there's a
grind to do you know it's like guys I
stepped away I was like five or seven he
felt like it done most of it I wanted to
come back try it out and then all of a
sudden this grind is still really slow
couple weeks earlier would've made a
difference and it's just kind of like oh
I don't I know it's not too little too
late I mean Dusty's gonna keep living
going right it's like there's just some
people got shut off pretty quick if it's
like those are some of the ones again
that's always we're saying what does it
take to get them back and it's like it
could be harder harder step now just
because of those things but at least we
can say some things are in place to be
like hey a couple weeks we'll make come
on back
you know you've taken me a couple weeks
off the grinds a lot quicker so come on
back I'll help you through it you know
be a nice way to talk to some friends
back in yeah absolutely like I said like
you said you know a lot of this is gonna
be a learning experience when they drop
this new style of annual past content
with endgame in mind you know now they
have to figure it looks like they may be
figured it out you know as far as like
not leaving the old content the people
who are still working on the old content
behind so like you said learning
experience and hopefully they document
and you know get that thing moving
smooth for the next one which is uh was
a joke as well we got ya Joker's loyal
to be I guess March or I mean whatever
you want to call spring because spring
is always like March 21st or 22nd so
however close they feel like getting to
that but I mean this was basically I
mean December 4th so if you did three
months it'd be almost start of March I
think mmm absolutely absolutely but yeah
guys I know we said upcoming changes for
flashpoint on the thumbnail
I'll let kognito start this one off
nothing crazy but we talked about so
when is your ears yeah man we got to get
to it um so it's come to my attention
that uh obviously you know absolutely
started flashpoint in the beginning of
this year and I'm a man in Pontus and
you know just the podcast focused you
know during the time at the game is at
its lowest so you know it's definitely a
passion project for us and we really
appreciate the support so yes there was
some slight exaggeration in the tweaks
that I put out but um it's basically
kind of my attention that there is
another entity using this name so
basically there's there's been no legal
action nothing against us like that but
this is more of a preventative measure
so we probably want to be in the process
of talking amongst ourselves as well as
when to bring it to you guys attention
because you know for me personally the
flashpoint name really means a lot to me
I mean obviously it's not super original
Bungie had it but you know it's an
activity it was things you had to do and
then obviously we had the inside joke
you know flash with the quotation marks
that you know we when many bonds get
going on destinies nothing never quick
it's for its discussion but um yeah man
so basically you know with brainstorming
we we're probably looking at a rebrand
of the name you know we don't want this
thing to stop at least I don't want this
thing to stop it's very important to me
it's very important I'm sorry about this
and how we work and just talking about
this game that we love so you know we
probably want to take some suggestions
you know we got to the new year and we
definitely want to rebrand we definitely
want to come up with something that
ultimately represents us but at the same
time still represent destiny and my only
request is it I don't prefer to have the
bit word podcast in it but get help it
you know
help not be like blah blah blah podcasts
and there's nothing against that it's
just like kind of we just want ours to
be on more on the unique side so it's
kind of what we'd like to stick with
which is why the flashpoint thing really
hurts me I know he watches his read he's
like look man he's ready to go on
like it's one of those things when you
were telling me about it's like I do
understand yeah it's like the name
changes kind of one of those things it's
like but I mean we're still it's been
less than a year we're coming up on
coming right up on the year but it'll be
a you know reasonable time to change but
when you were telling me that story that
your friend was talking to a his to two
hits friend saying yeah and listen to
this like podcasts a little bit it's a
couple of these guys out there and then
all of a sudden he's like dude I know
those guys and it's like that was just
making me smile so in the moment I
wasn't quite as down as you were cause
he's like oh man it's like I want to
lose the name but here's the story it
got you really low and for me I just
like that's the good side of that story
like it was just a really cool like
couple random people out there's no we
are it's like I know it's a small world
sometimes so that was actually really
really cool but yeah it's like we're
just trying to find some a new name for
this one and we don't know quite what's
gonna be so if you guys have suggestions
whether you're listening to this later
on YouTube or post something up on
Twitter anything but yeah I mean as as
Cognito is saying it's just something
that doesn't include the word podcast so
we can just keep it kind of short and
sweet for the title but something just
kind of represents us maybe some destiny
relation and if not just some way we're
kind of freaky and feel a tie back into
it would be will be what we're going for
so absolutely shout who else goes to
offer and ride a professional in each at
a fried refreshment says he's changing
his name also you got to go through it
to the 30-day all right so I don't feel
bad as bad now right if you got to go
through it and you've been around you've
been putting out great content man so
salute to you being in here great you
too or please if you guys are not a way
up place it should I call you
PlayStation centric but I he's good he's
a good dude man and definitely saluted
us when we hit the 1000 mark on our lost
podcast port oh yeah it's just one of
those things it was it's like you said
he bought it it was like shout out to
ivan AKA anchorman he randomly hits me
up but he's like yeah i'm in this gaming
group and i know a bunch of pc guys and
they just got destiny you know since it
went free initially and um you know it
was one of those things where he's like
yeah we listened to this cool podcast
with these two guys so you know
anchorman saying hmm and then he's like
what's the name of it no matter he
actually didn't ask that he's been
talking to for a while then one day
he goes home he goes to him he's like I
guess he must have screenshotted
flashpoint he's like is it these guys
anyone like yeah kognito his bundles
Myka I just like dude I know them but
right so like that it was like the
timing of it right babe I'm like oh man
so yeah we need to do named y'all man
you know like I say if you want to put
in the comments you know on my page or
in pastas page or Twitter you know maybe
we actually eat maybe we come up with
like a some more Twitter as well to
start like kind of festering in
suggestions what you think ah yeah I
mean we'll serve something out there
I'll throw something on my channel just
for the community post
I mean I'll put the podcast up but that
after I give that a day or two but just
say hey if you guys have any thoughts
we're looking at a name change so any
suggestions we're open just trying to
leave the word podcast out of it it's
pretty much all I'm gonna say and just
yes you if anybody throws anything out
there that you know strikes a chord with
us and absolutely actually the last
thing I'll say on it before we move on
is that um you know I don't want to put
our super rush on it but I would ideally
in a perfect world we'd like to get this
thing going you know but for for 2019 I
mean like me like to start at beginning
of 2019 obviously we've got no more
table so I believe you know saying until
ok I got the date it's like it's the I
think it's like the 10th or something
like that probably like yeah you'd have
Navi labs would be the 8th another
calendar would probably be the 11th or
something else yeah some to that effect
so you know just get the rebrand kicking
off and you know that obviously we still
the plan is still to go to Guardian
carnage that you know the plan is out
there so it would be nice to get the
ball rolling on that so just food for
thought help us out get flashpoint a
home in the name I mean it's kind of
like a flashpoint work because it's like
hey little quick sum up destiny of the
things you do so if you guys can pull
another thing like that out of your butt
great if you come up with something you
need to throw it out there so we'll be
looking at all don't take any offense if
we don't pick yours what's up dramatic
and you me and Cyn irrelevance Cole and
Ryan all you guys jumping in this
morning early I don't know where you
guys are at but if it's earlier late
thanks for tuning in because I know
mm-hmm
yeah so just working on the name but
yeah if we don't pick yours just trust
you can throw six of Madison
care we'll look at them all we'll just
figure out and honestly sometimes it
could be just that one that clicks and
that's me I know myself I'm I'm picky
when it comes to stuff so even just
working on my logo it's like I'm sure
the crap out of the guy who I had make
it but he was patient with me not kinda
I wanted worked with some options and
then I mean it's the same thing with you
I'm sure so there's and it could be like
six ones that are almost the same and
there's one that has this something that
wins out so I was like that's why for me
it's just gonna be I can't even say what
we're looking I'm specifically looking
for I'm just gonna have to see it when I
do yeah absolutely I mean like I said my
only requirement so I said like I said
only for those who just joined in the
room shout the game and Forte what's up
my fellow Guardians what's up man
Forte we need a new name baby we need a
new name the feds is on us now just
joking yeah that seriously we try to do
every branch so well my like I said my
only thing is again for you guys that
watch that you know the tune in you guys
know us you know our style you know kind
of how we operate you know so something
that kind of represents us something
that's kind of Destiny related and um
yeah like I said my only requirements
like you said II is just you know I
prefer not to have destiny in the name
cuz you know I'm saying it's like
everybody's kind of doing it you know
everybody's like destiny podcast yadda
yadda yeah you know saying and I
preferred not to have podcast in there
so I don't make any kind of difficult
but something that represents destiny so
you kind of know like that's what was
cool about flash but you kind of knew
that term if you're if you play the game
you know it's synonymous with that and
the latter for tell Becca for tell you
late well pretty much what happened it's
what they were just being preventative
we're being preventative we have seen
the flash Nate point name circulating
and um we don't want to get into
anything down the road especially going
to Guardian con and we want to represent
ourselves correctly and not get any
legal actions that's what's going on
[Laughter]
that's what I got on it yeah so nothing
crazy just trying to definitely make
things our own I mean you go flashpoint
you'll see there's them I think it's
like an eSports team right yeah I'm
gonna put it in both our chats so that
both of our our audiences understand
what we're up against
and be literally just Google flex when
you even look up images I mean flash
once also related to actually the flash
I mean that's a whole thing there you
there's a TV series with that so I mean
there's enough things out there where
it's like just kind of need something
for differentiation so yeah absolutely
no sinister we are not the travelers
speakers we are not doing that that's
what he was for the rebrand we got well
we got the business out the way yeah
just join them what you missed art see
we're looking at a name change nothing
crazy just getting ahead of it so anyway
moving on so quick patch did happen on
Tuesday some good things though these
are ones we were talking about with
helping the lower level players try and
get leveled up there were some
activities that had some quick fixes
we'll go final boss encounter of scores
of the past would not improperly wear
bug where players were not getting
things they were supposed to be doing so
just some patches that were fixed they
fix some heavy spawning issues and then
the big ones were the items in the
economy so players under 600 may now
receive high powered rewards when
completing director challenges whether
it's daily or weekly now that's a lot
mm-hmm
but if you go how many dailies that
you're gonna get which ends up probably
being about you know roughly seven or
eight since the adventure always seems
to duplicate yeah then you got the you
know weekly bounties that you can do all
of those things are gonna count so it's
like I mean they've added they've added
some boosts and if they give that higher
level like it may still take like a week
or two but doesn't feel it's gonna take
like two months which is I think what
they really need to ramp up and then you
can slow slow down close to right around
600 but oh you know ramp those lower
players up quicker you got to do it yeah
I've been feeling the effects of that I
have little I I do feel that this update
has has definitely paid off in that
regard specifically see this is a great
thing you've been our test subject your
app your realm so hey it's worked out
for time oh yeah and that's for some of
those too it's like even for me if I
wanted to go be like hey somebody really
wants to play on ps4 I don't know if I
can go back to ps4 unless it was like
cross Dave because literally just
grinded it out there somebody's like hey
I really want to play or I did some
test maybe then but generally like I
think I'll still be PC but mm-hmm if
there's ever like another character
class we had and or something like that
just speeding up would be nice yeah
absolutely uh they said the fixed nation
where players were not rewarded properly
when completing a force that was joined
in progress fix an issue and weapon
frames were removed from inventory which
was a big one for a lot of people yes
that was kind of a bummer I know you're
getting close to getting into those but
yeah try and keep one in your inventory
at all times they say that you can do
two now but I don't know if I trust them
I got one done I mean I got one pretty
much done now it's just I got to do some
four to finish it I think what it is I
jumped in a public space and there was
some haya paya Guardians like killing
one of those things and I got the box
and I got the frame so literally last
step of it now is to actually enter the
forge to get the machine gun or
something you said 580 ish you know my
580 ish yeah you kind of get stepped on
in there yeah we need to go over to
those parts like that yeah but I mean
hey if that's the only piece you got to
do once you get in there and if people
especially like if you get me scream
couple of people that have been in it
for a little bit that are higher if you
can just not get completely whooped and
like instantly we can probably drag you
through especially the first one you can
go whisper that guy in the corner pretty
easy just go whisper in his ear with a
big giant sniper rifle and then buh-bye
they said that removed removed a shader
fiction issue where players weren't
properly being granted the sparrow for
the eggs that I know is a big one for a
lot of people because they've been
hunting them down from the six different
weeks of the Ascend challenges and all
that stuff so finally given that thing
to drop for people which is good and
then they missed they remove the annual
pass requirement for claiming the
curator of the black armory triumphs so
I don't see anything in here where the
mods can still be purchased without the
annual patch can you buy the mods yet I
cheated no cuz remember I told you no
you don't finish the forge and that's
usually what it said you had to do but I
can do it now because whatever happened
again I must have been at a public event
and guys were fighting that you know
what are those uh those bosses from my
bosses but when I was like Lowell
I value targets yeah and they have those
little dings spinning around them when
you got a shoot to bring the shield down
yeah that's just a saboteur that's not
that's not the Forge right no it's not
the Forge what I'm saying is whatever
whenever they beat that thing there was
something in the box that I picked up
yeah I mean that started this long chest
quake you know there's this whole chest
thing it's just quest like it just kept
going and going it's kill this dude that
kill that and then at the very step it
was like to do the force right but then
when I saw a de this week the
availability to buy mods
opened up for me now hmm see that's what
I'm wondering is if it is mm-hmm
I need somebody who like doesn't have
the annual past until I tell me that's
cuz yeah just because for I mean for me
weapon mods not being available for
those who don't have a know past as a
like big slap in the face for those who
don't just cuz they're very crucial part
of I mean Banshee and mods you should be
able to buy mod components like that's a
thing so if anybody out there knows if
you don't have the annual pass and
you're playing and you check with Ada if
you can even get her I don't even know
if you can open her up
so that's why I was like yeah but he's a
bingo when when I first started you know
and I went to her that it mods were not
available for me it was like grayed out
like I had to complete steps and do
stuff so it's interesting now that it I
have the ability to actually buy them I
don't know kind of beerus eventually get
some clarification but i know that's the
thing a couple other little fixes they
did fix the avalanche machine gun as I
said had more recoil than intended so
they kind of toned that one down the
other voices was doing more damage on PC
and that has been fixed as well so
nothing crazy pre small I mean they're
going into a quiet time for them as well
or they're not gonna push out anything
crazy and then take vacation for two
weeks I mean people are still gonna be
working but in general this is like this
is not the time to be like let's change
a bunch of stuff and see what happens
this is let's tweak a few things and
leave it as is for a bit so hmm seems
like the time to not get too crazy with
the changes so yeah fairly smart smart
oh but yeah this week at Bungie I think
I'm gonna have to go back and read your
like the entire chat cuz you guys are
coming up with names in the fly on or
like
the actual stuff and there's like 20
posts about names all right you already
working on it yeah oh yeah this week at
Bungie last one of the year 2018 is
wrapping up it has been a crazy year
just for one because we've been doing
this the whole time so shout out to iron
Lords podcast by the way getting their
thousand sub mark broken juicer whoa
thank you sir very cool man grats guys
if you haven't if you haven't something
over there do it but I mean they got
their thousand subs are gonna keep
climbing and growing awesome content so
just wanted a quick shout out there I
have to opportunity but thank you yeah
so this week the Izanami Forge dropped
people were losing their minds at the
question I haven't done it yet but I do
know it's a lengthy one so have you even
heard anything about this question yet
I've heard about it I've heard it's
pretty brutal would you do um yeah it's
definitely not a short one so I mean
just the way it starts to play all of
them have been go kill vex till this one
thing's drops that starts it yeah and
then you've got like you have to do
specific public events a couple times
you have to this thing has I'm scrolling
through it like ten steps nine maybe
mm-hmm but it ends with like a six
thirty basically nightfall yeah and
that's the one I think that's getting
everybody like you can grind some of the
other stuff out it's not gonna be easy
some of the other forges are involved
but you have the 6:30 strike finish
that's gonna be the hard one
yeah that's pretty intense so what did I
get your thoughts on the idea of when
you unlock the fort you like cool up
going through this character you got
your tighten up you're like alright
going through you bring that next
character up you gotta take them through
the full quest chain again what do you
think of what do you think of that
because I mean in a sense they are a
different character but we have accounts
I mean it's like if I think of World of
Warcraft I mean I feel like Sean Penn
again half the time on here yeah I agree
yeah but it is one of those two where
it's like so it's another case
it's like if I'm gonna go unlock
something yeah I probably had to go do
it again but it's like in dusty it feels
it feels a little weirder than World of
Warcraft to have to go do it again
because like I look at my consumables
and those are still like this same
across all accounts pursuits maybe
different but like consumables and
shaders and those things are still their
weapons I can toss between them it's not
like you know I have a warlock and I
have a warrior and they don't even like
talk in any way shape fashion or foreign
it's truly like this is an alternate
character and if you're gonna level it
up you got to do it again as some of our
stuff talks and some doesn't in this the
repeating of like a quest chain yeah I
don't know even if it was like if you've
done it on a member care could be like
hey we know you will unlock this on
another character let's go you know
either wrap this up or maybe just have
to do the nightfall again you don't have
to grind out the other stuff maybe you
just have to do the hardest part just
prove that you're kind of at the right
level you're not kind of getting dragged
in because I think some of this which
has actually been a good thing mm-hmm
no I got basically I was gonna say is as
the forges have gone on the quests that
have required higher levels like 6:24
League go fan and forge which I just got
done with this one has a 630 they're
doing some power gating in there so
you're not gonna go matchmaking to
something that your way under leveled
for the first one people are seeing then
they're like I'm being match made with
like five ATS they're wasting my time I
don't even know how that got in this in
the first place but they shouldn't be in
there and they're just dying all the
time the other four just seemed like the
matchmaking while I mean it's not gonna
be an easy thing to do if people don't
know what they're doing right but the
level in there at least seems to be a
consistent piece that I've seen like
going into go fan and I haven't seen
anybody like jumping in that's not been
like you know six twenty to twenty five
like most have been in a pretty solid
spot so I'm kind of hoping the like
leveling of the quest that they require
kind of put people in the proper place
so yeah I agree I mean I think they're
trying to allude into your overall being
as far as like it being access being
from a character level as opposed to an
account level yeah I would agree which I
mean this is you know this is high in
conquer this is end content I get it in
game arm but it's one of those things
where it's like
to make that level of requirement for
all your characters ruff and I kind of I
kind of grew what you said which is like
there should be maybe like a almost like
a checkpoint right so to speak so that
if you do pick up with another character
and you have completed you know all the
forges that that's at least maybe you're
farther along in the quest line to a lot
as opposed to them all the way being a
lot for the newer or secondary character
that you attempted to put it through
what do you feel yeah I mean just
something because I've seen the bird
hold on it offered destiny 2/4 Forge
mm-hmm I'm trying to find the name of it
it's like the Burgas II it's the one
that I've heard mention out there Karen
both tap camera love tap come on
and it was on reddit and basically I've
see I saw the list of things that you
have to do for that mm-hmm oh man if you
think this one is long yeah
you better you better strap in and get
ready that's what I'm hearing from for -
thing a lot of it's not difficult but
just time-consuming just mundane kind of
grindy stuff right that's the vibe -
like they're trying to utilize most of
their content which is I think kind of a
good thing and some of its like there
were little tweaks like on it was the go
fan and quest and you'll get there sorry
spoiler warning but it's a step but you
talk about spider and he's like man
whoever it is out here they're stealing
my stuff go out there and go say hello
and then I want to hear some skulls
cracking you literally have to go melee
people so that's like you're saying
hello by punching them in the face so if
you give just a little twist on that
that it was like okay that's actually
kind of hilarious mm-hmm that one's kind
of cool like little steps in there that
I caught on that one we're kind of fun
if they had more and I think in all of
this it would have been and again I
don't know the budgets and things like
that but as we go through any of these
forged
just to make them not feel quite so go
do this checkbox okay go do this
checkbox okay go do this checkbox okay a
little bit of voiceover here and there
maybe would have been cool yeah just
like you finished the quest you click a
box and hey it's like okay this one's
done click on it it'll activate some
voiceover wherever you're at just so
that one's playing and then I'll work on
your next step but just a little bit to
kind of guide you through or give you
incentive to go through especially that
second time would have been I think it
excuse me my opinion quite helpful no I
agree
here's the thing Forte actually made it
I suggest he said they should make the
grind like they do for a weapon frame
once you forged the item once you should
only have to do the story missions and
skip all the farming ads and Matt he
said plus can we please stop going back
to ADA oh that's that's kind of those
things like some words I go back and
forth a couple times
be nice to in it's that balance he said
do I need to go punch 75 guys in the
face do I need to go get you know fallen
kills with precision shots to get these
things to drop those parts the grindy
pieces bills aren't really helping me
level up or anything but if I go through
and I do something that's got a powerful
drop or I go through and I do a power
level check yeah a couple pieces that
would be cool mmm-hmm we know they know
accounts talk to each other
but be a knight that's kind of one of
those things it doesn't feel like it
needs to be like a full like hey you're
done just go walk in but just to check
for that character couple things cool
yeah I agree
what did finalists it's the burgoo Xia
Forge I was so spoiler warning guys
coming up in about five rules for her be
Niobe Labs quote release four three two
one and all right so the burger Xia
Forge this is on reddit I think this was
farmed but I'm gonna let you guys know
just so you have an idea what to expect
and this I think is more why you're like
uh okay
we're beating this three times is gonna
put some length in it he'll taking Kings
which I don't actually know what those
are
I'm not sure until you get the starter
so it's usually that little pick up
mm-hm
uh talk dataone collect 25 eyes of an
arm car
hmm interesting
yeah I'm not sure if you're gonna happen
that's it you almost have to raid great
that's like that means this sounds like
due to raid and what's the eyes of aah
honk are like little enemies somewhere
that I just don't remember and they're
called that but hmm completely ether
ritual heroic public event while getting
10 precision kills on abominations so
that's two different things talk to
spider yeah
finish the hallowed lair nightfall with
arc singe at 200,000 mm this is all
starting to sound like it's insane so
I'm like this crap but the way like
number nine went if they're gonna make
the hardest one like the longest chain
it wouldn't some of this mm-hmm
no 75 invaders with sidearms while
airborne in gambit troll with us it is
ready that seems the same I think
they're making stuff up at this point
self what I did want to actually kind of
bring that stuff up because I was
getting in there I was like okay this is
a little insane but I wanted to kind of
get a joke in there but the idea is like
that would actually give scoring in a
nightfall like a purpose cool just
because I mean 200k is kind of insane
but just to give you an soon would be
like hey if you're about 6:30 you can
take a modifier on a night follow up to
about 90 and then 200k on some night
falls is doable it's not easy but it's
doable and that's why is for you and the
Android known as esoteric those are the
only two people capable of doing these
things like 75 invaders in gambit I
would be finishing that thing up like um
you know destiny 3 it wasn't her to tell
you come out with your reckoning video
[Laughter]
good invisible thing you figure so about
that's a great got it's got to be a
trophy
it's got like it it absolutely has to be
so yeah there's no way but I just want
to give you guys a little joke control
on that one so but it is one of those
where as the questions get longer
it is one of those where I think it's
it's gonna definitely take some work
like they're gonna go through I mean the
current one you do and this is Izanami
you've got to do final little piece you
charge up that transponder that you get
you have to do the spire integration so
you have to wait for a specific heroic
event heroic public event then you have
to kill twenty vex minotaurs in a
specific area not the easiest things to
do somebody was saying there's actually
an adventure that helps with that
complete the forge mission itself so
usually gonna complete the Izanami Forge
and start a quest then you've got more
public events to do you've got to
collect materials for the igniter go do
another Forge and then come back down do
the 630 strike and then you're good now
go and that's just the one that's open
right now Wow
so that's why I was like I haven't even
gotten into that one just cuz I haven't
had time to sit down and just like grind
away so so let me ask you a quick
question for those you know like me who
have not stepped foot in one voyage you
know like the grind itself like what are
you doing for optimal because I'm trying
to prepare myself because obviously at
6:02 is approaching for me right so what
it what's the optimal thing you're doing
to get yourself prepped for each of
these floors like you're just doing your
normal milestones like kind of like what
I'm doing or is there something else it
is that to level up artsy's over there
the strikes harder than the Forge I'm
not gonna dab it because the 6:30 strike
is no joke yeah basically it's just been
I mean every powerful it's almost like
when you're leveling up when we were
about 500 before it's like okay what's
the efficient way
Hailee's do your weekly basics like here
in camp as your crucible matches strike
stuff like that night falls I usually
get my double drop in there a little bit
later and dreaming city starts to drop
stuff a little bit higher so you won't
get the crazy boast but then do that
then you can work on like the forges but
it's like that's kind of your
progression as going back through as we
were leveling up before he gamez over
there saying he does his dreaming city
first to get more light and honestly
that's an option too so and I mean you
guys have seen different videos out
there if you're leveling up if there's
if you're looking for if
most your stuff close to a similar level
and go do something in the dreaming city
whether it's the mission whether it's
those that's gonna give you a big boost
and their little ones are gonna start
filling in the gaps if you're missing a
giant hole somewhere know do a couple of
little ones to see if you can get that
hole filled you know that's actually
pretty small and I've been I know in the
past I've said like I've kind of saved
dreaming city stuff for last but I've
been actually I've actually been
applying that now that I've been on PC
which is just to go there first and yet
don't you'll knock out so much more
powerful here and you'll jump up faster
than the gap is bigger so I do agree I
do agree with that yeah so well shout
out to chant saying basically what I was
saying was backwards but yeah do the
dreaming city stuff first get your big
boost night falls the rest of stuff fill
in the gaps so yeah I know you got these
up there I think I saw him in like 649
blows crow buzz up to 6:45 in your chat
so the grind is doable and people are
getting up there the people who are up
at 6:44 like 650 for the raid in three
days yeah they were teeny not cheatin
but they were just uh saving things yes
mm-hmm
so that's what I've been doing so I mean
that's yeah it's it's gonna be back to
playing it's the same stuff I mean
before you can get to that forward you
gotta kind of get your light level up
and that first one if you're like eh if
only gets a six hundred let me go try it
so I'm gonna hurt 25 and unless you
cheese it if you're going into randoms
oh yeah that's rough
mmm you may pair up now where you might
get one that's like hey 610 605 and then
maybe a 650 who can go mop the floor
with everybody in there but if your
random luck of people you're paired up
with our more blueberry side yeah you're
gonna be struggling till you get higher
mmm that's one of those pieces about
matchmaking I think everybody can
probably agree matchmaking raids please
no mm-hmm
I mean unless they truly just like dumb
down the mechanics to like easy mode
level where it's like hey throw this one
ball over here and then throw it at this
guy to drop the shield I mean it's gonna
have to be really basic stuff to ever
consider
matchmaking but honestly like that wood
can defeat the purpose so
one of those things where you gotta go
look for some people to play with yeah
your gummies basically saying sixteen
and the first forge still hurts so mm
okay okay no I'm glad you tell them this
because I have to it's good mental
preparation for me that even though I'm
600 I'm gonna get smashed if I try to
step it just so you don't get
disheartened either I mean that's one of
those things you say let's see six oh
five six ten like what do you think I
should be the fly attempt that fever
about six first I'm for comfort with
randoms closer to six ten okay and then
just the closer you get because the boss
will be at sixteen six twenty six twenty
five is though enemy level in there so I
mean if you're six ten and if you get
like six eleven and just get that one
level so it's not that perfect ten it
may make a difference too but somewhere
right in there I mean I beat it at 6:04
first mmm I knew like whisper and a
cheese I can pull a couple friends over
and do that but if people don't know
what they're doing
yeah I've only beaten the first four
whisper the second one is that's all
different discussion altogether but that
first one yeah it's gonna be one of
those things that's higher you are the
better - you might be making up for
people that are clueless mm-hmm yeah
well I'm glad I got I got my well
irradiance now a guy like that yeah
alone would be huge like even if I'm
about to anybody else like go in there
you could be six hundred if you just can
stay alive alive and keep all of our
Gideon's and all you shoot I'm trying to
think if the axiom bolts aren't that one
or not but basically like you do that
kind of stay alive and then when the
second rounds is the one that's gonna
kill you the most but at least two
people can probably manage if they're
high enough but the third one yeah if
you get to stay eleven Popplewell or
eighty and see how we can probably mop
the floor with the boss mm-hmm so you
know having people you know that are
higher will help a lot actually
but yeah the Izanami Forge sounds cool
actually hear from what people are
playing I saw you on Twitter you got me
as well basically saying the new forge
is your favorite so I mean you got me if
you want to show shout out something
inch in chat just saying why I'm kind of
curious why be the new for just kind of
the favorite Forge from some people have
been seeing that while the grind to get
there is aa rough the fort itself sounds
kind of cool from yeah anybody in chat
who's do
got the explain that to us I'm very
curious yeah I mean from what I've
gathered there's like moto it's vex but
there are multiple platforms so you kind
of have the center platform where the
boss would be kind of located now or the
main what am i thinking the main forge
where you throwing the batteries into it
is at but it almost seems like people in
the other platforms they're like down
low or somewhat farther away
they're like picking up and chucking
batteries to the middle section and cuz
I watched a quick little clip and some
dude is just picking up and throwing
batteries into the forge but there's
nothing any enemies on his platform like
they're putting working on both sides
throwing the batteries up to him and the
one in the middle is just chucking them
in the middle and trying to do stuff
from long range so it sounds like kind
of a cool mechanic actually just the way
they've got it separated on kind of the
platforms as opposed to just one big
open space yeah awesome but yeah I'll be
working on getting that grind going soon
also shattered throws this week I got
that done with a couple buddies as well
you know that's one for you if you
haven't done it this week definitely get
that one in because that's at least
three pretty sizable drops for you so
yeah that's a good point but I mean what
was a if you could remember do you
remember like recommended for that cuz I
might have 85 90 right there right there
okay right there yeah I mean if you're
580 you could definitely do it yeah
because people did it before that but
580 the final boss is 590 so that final
room it's yeah 590 so if you're 580 you
could if you grant a few more things
over the weekend or something like that
but I would definitely say is like I'm
gonna be out of town come Sunday but if
you can find some people to get you in
shadow thrown it's worth it for the
drops for sure yeah actually that I'm
actually my own Mii Yuu I gotta speak to
scream and a cruel we we gotta get up we
got to get last wish started just for
some drops and stuff before I even
attempt scourge yeah I haven't run a
last wish at all on PC and I'm very
curious to run first one so once you get
back maybe for validating stuff maybe we
figure it out yeah no I was like trust
me last wish a couple times the fourth
score I mean scores is like last that
sucker six but yeah even shout-out to
dramatic did the shattered throne last
night with this clan kiks kiks bud like
a mini r8 nose like so I love that thing
it's so much fun yeah just all the
secrets buried in there are really
really cool too so uh yeah so they
mention in here as well the community is
currently solving puzzles and uncovering
oh that's kind of things that people are
not quite knowing yet unless they
haven't dug deep mm-hmm and when you go
through and start getting the guns from
these forges the first quest you unlock
a gun that specific gun can see these
like glyphs that only literally show up
through the sights of that guy yeah
shoot those things in order get those
things going those look crest those are
starting to unlock they've got the
mysterious box that you get from keys
that the little drones that you shoot
like the secrets of these things have
been really cool and that's the Bungie
side that they did not forget yes so and
those are some of the ones that Bailey
go I'm too high level and then they're
missing out on the little stuff that is
there they just had to get to it that's
why I was like I want people to get to
these little pieces and start seeing all
the cool stuff they put in gadget now
let me ask you this quick long point
question quick question open can of
worms go here we go this might be the
last time I get to say that so now what
I was gonna say was like being that you
have experienced a majority of so far
you know the content like how are you
feeling about the forge system in
general this is in game you know
obviously we are but we're gonna discuss
said cinema that we really spoiled a
couple of flash let's go yeah but um you
know like just in general you're
knee-deep in it I see you out there you
know in these black armory streets so uh
so what do you feel like what about the
walk around it's not just the streets
sidewalks I got trees I like whole long
walks on the beach what are you talking
about come on beaches how do you feel
about this like as content its I think
dramatic said it pretty well the season
is getting cooler as you get more into
the forges people have said like some of
the guns that you start getting it was
the kindred or
the hand cannon from last week there's
some awesome roles that are coming on
that and it's really like you've got
control over the god role you want to
get and to unlock a forge if you're
working on the pulse rifle say this week
from the Izanami Forge which I hear is
damn good if you finished that quest
line and you want to go okay go right
back in so go pick up the because once
you do the weapon frame that's kind of a
longer chain to unlock it for the week
okay but then once you've unlocked that
one you get a cheaper one that you can
go get and that one you can do like
multiple times much quicker okay so just
go to two pieces and then go back in the
Forge mm-hmm so the fact that if you
want a specific thing you can now grind
for it now this is in or if you decide
is this something I enjoy doing and
that's a question for everybody um and
it depends a lot if you like if you like
destiny it's more of destiny so there's
more grinding in there but I mean if
you're like hey this pulse rifle feels
good I know there's better rolls out
there hey I could spend my week
literally just in these anime for it to
pick that thing up over and over and
over and over and see what you can do to
try and get it as the best as possible
that's actually kind of cool if you're
looking to train if you have a way to go
back for that god roll consistently now
my guess is these are gonna be tied to
like weekly rotations on which forges
active and which weapons are active so
you might have to wait a little while
but while it's up it's cool so I'm kind
of enjoying that the forges can be cool
when done well the quest chains up to
them I wish as we kind of just got done
talking about the the cross character
stuff was a little shortened or
abbreviated people have got the exotic
bow drop and now which is starting to
make people go crazy
Jimbo he said he's got to exotic boats
are you crazy you got to lemon arc
status yeah but yeah you got me saying
the pulse-width feeding frenzy is just
nuts what's the name of it it's like
black was it furnished last blast
furnace yeah okay I'm like that I think
I know it's something close to that oh
and it is just like it seems really cool
I mean people are saying it's an awesome
pulse rifle and pulse rifles are in the
meta right now so I mean that's why on
top of everything else it's just like
it's will probably want
you want to grind for us that's one of
the things in the next like day or two
before I go traveling but I want to try
and at least get one of no idea what my
role is gonna be able I want to get one
in my belt so don't question that's
specific to which Forge so I know right
now it's the Izanami so you're gonna
have to I don't know if you'll be high
enough I kind of doubt it okay
you might have to wait for that next
audition no this hero in my chest
basically a cool thing about the new
Forge and the quest line for the forges
they introduce a new enemy with new
mechanics and new jumping puzzle with
different mechanics so it's a really
really new content so that's kind of the
piece the people who and I forget who
said it but it's like the annual pass
you're not buying new content you're
buying a subscription to it you really
are because as they drip-feed this stuff
to you it's if you're still playing so
working on leveling still getting newer
things those are ways that they're
letting you and this is kind of I've
heard other people talk about it and we
can kind of get into it as well you have
two options yeah and this is the point
where if you guys go back and think
about what your experiences have been
like taking King was a really cool
experience had a whole lot of quests to
it but then we had that ginormous
drought after it and that was kind of a
big deal but we had a lot of cool stuff
we really enjoyed it the raid was cool
all of those things but after you know a
month or two of heavy grinding which is
old I mean a lot for any game but that
you're gonna like step away for five or
six months I wait for that big chunk how
was curse of osiris ii received besides
a giant dumpster fire and we know it I
mean it was it was just like mercury was
terrible like the apartment 2d was like
kind of a shoot things that I know you
weren't a fan of people actually really
enjoy the argos encounter itself yeah if
people like but just in general it's
like serving it's like we're my story
missions and stuff like that I'm like
okay so the story missions that you play
one time
then now that you have to go back and do
story missions for the one of the
challenges for the week you look I've
done these so many times like story
missions once you do and they don't
really quite have that feel that you're
like I want to go back and do these
again right and you don't have
randomized why are they not randomized
in there I don't understand it why
they'd like kind of force you to pick
that like specific ones you noticed that
oh just it's like well they give you
five I mean and they change a lot they
treat it like the strike we're just you
know just going I don't want to think of
like play list and be like hey yeah it's
like I mean I'm on I wish they would do
like a story playlist and just be like
hey anything's on the table because
there's some times I was looking for a
triumphs to do and it would be you know
go do this one thing it's like nope
those aren't active so I'm not gonna go
do it so it was like I got to go kill
Gaul on a heroic mission then somehow on
whatever character I haven't done the
heroic Gaul mission again so at some
point I have to look for that yeah
but yeah little stuff I mean honestly it
would be nice because it would be just
as you said I don't care which mission I
know I have to do three of them so let
me just see which ones I get oh I could
do fight pin opting to the war mind and
see anti brave for the first time
whatever it is I'd be kind of cool yeah
absolutely
but you but you have those little pieces
of contour you have you know your war
mines those Osiris and they spend time
there's no easy way to do a mission with
voice or over make those spaces that
they do have the cinematics those are
all development cycle time that they
have to try and figure out where they're
gonna spend it so you can either have
story missions that you enjoy kind of
once and then one or they're trying to
do what they're doing now and it's it's
a completely different feel and they're
learning from it yes but I mean we got
one Forge and we got a raid in another
Forge and then we got this new forged
here on you know got the turn to think
time wise ya know and so he had the newt
the first forge and we have no fan and
forge right oh we had the Donny startup
that was on me alone right we just got
this Forge coming right of course the
holidays and Christmas is gonna be a
thing so that's like a little time off
come back we've got the Niobe labs which
they talked about here and there's gonna
be potentially another Forge in there
which is the burger Zia Forge so all of
those pieces are continually coming then
you're probably gonna have crimson days
at the start of February they've got the
quest for last word coming up if there's
anything secret in there and then BAM
we're in March like if you are someone
who enjoys destiny and this is something
you actually enjoy even if it is you
just log in on Tuesday do some stuff
kind of get a feel for it go play some
other things but you still keep coming
back on Tuesday week after
after week after week that is a good
thing for them because you're not
stepping away for four months you might
step away for four or five days right so
you never feel like you're too detached
from everything that's going on it's not
like you're gonna step back in and
September me like what the hell did I
miss right no I get it it's a different
approach I mean I will say this that you
know I don't know what we're getting
into the what you call it the the Oracle
thing what we're gonna get we're gonna
get it today oh we not touch that we can
sure well I'm not gonna Wow see we've
already discussed it right well spoiler
is I mean if you guys haven't done it
please do it we know there's certainly
someone that is back but my question is
like I was actually surprised we got a
cinematic thing for that right so the
way I look at it is also this if they
continue to do what they do with this
Aldrin thing and we're literally
extending forsaken story if you look at
it right you know oh yeah
based on what's going on so if they do
that with like a little drop here and
there and I kind of kindig-it I kind of
could because I really thought that was
very well done you know I'm saying we
we've talked about it you know at
nauseam before you know the the
ramifications and what it could mean I'm
not gonna get into that again but the
whole thing to me is just like I've
never seen them do this you know it
almost feels like um you know like you
watch a series on Netflix or something
and it's like you know - in the next
episode what's gonna happen now that the
Queen knows you know saya cuz she's not
there when you go you know you delivered
you know the Oracle engine thing so I'm
very curious with this style of
storytelling if they keep the quality up
if if the fan base because let's be real
if that wasn't spoiled ii think about
how height we would be even more so
right now oh yeah like would have lost
our mind basically like what the sense
that you and me like dude did you you
gotta go but you're offering to the
oracle go go go like
so I mean if it wasn't soiled either way
I mean when I still saw and like watch
them like what does that mean like I
want to know I know one giant thing
there is not a hunter Vanguard in the
tower
somehow someone I don't know who or
where it comes from now the hole has to
be filled with in the vanguard
eventually mmm-hmm to keep destiny in
the vanguard a thing otherwise it's
gonna get disbanded new nose but yeah
generally those three and you need that
third pillar back so some way that's
gonna be a thing which this opens up a
you know laundry bag of question marks
and honestly it's like I have no idea
how much people would lose their mind if
older and walked in that tower I mean
are you can you just like think of the
cinematic basically just pull it out of
Game of Thrones and so many of the
background and see if they had him walk
back in and there's like a slow
cinematic I've been walking mmm
somebody's gonna double that shame
somebody's gonna dump that over it like
just for the cinematic you know what
happens instantly oh I would to see is I
Cora's face oh man she just would
probably want to melt his face off oh
that would be that you know you boys
avala gonna be the diplomat okay but see
in that point like that's unfortunately
for his slave you know he's got a sack
up a little bit but yeah like that would
be the point where he would actually
need to step in and be like wait wait
wait remember it's like you've been in
the same boat you've been you've been a
guardian you knows what you were before
this is what he's is now right was like
remember he was chosen by the traveler
in The Guardian and all this like she
focuses on that's her whole world and
she just man talk about a woman of two
minds on that one she explode you so bad
yeah I also understand what's happening
here like man that would be like that
character art could be really really
really awesome he said the memes would
be amazing oh absolutely the the the the
interaction in a towel will be fantastic
can't wait to see how to handle it
obviously we know Mara's not there does
she go greet him
you know how what's her feeling on it
you know this and we know his mind is
white
clean the hunters dare the whole day it
is gonna be interesting so again if they
do this kind of a you know drip-feed
storytelling content you know that
extends Forsaken you know that could be
very cool right each we know between
each big content drop yeah I mean that's
kind of what I'm looking forward to is
if they can really start getting I mean
I've probably said it before I enjoy of
a TV shows that have longer arcs that
really mattered even a little weekly a
procedural type stuff while it's like
it's entertaining for the week it's the
bigger things that keep me going cuz
it's like now the killer of the week or
the crime of the week or mm-hm
I mean depends on the shows and that's
why some of the longer drawn-out like
other Netflix or AMC when it's all about
the nuance of little things that I enjoy
more so the more of this trust me I'm
gonna be happy with it yeah absolutely
so yeah so I mean Aldrin is gonna be
messing some stuff up we'll have to see
how it goes if you guys haven't seen
what we're talking about go turn you're
offering to the Oracle yeah offering of
the Oracle into the Oracle engine and
then go hop into Mars area and just just
finish around in there until you find
something that says lean closer and
girls in it worth watching oh yeah
but yeah 2018 is wrapping up the dawning
is still going the dawning goes into the
end of 2018 so happy new years is also
happy bye-bye a dawning kok-long you
need to for them if you are looking to
make your slay have that quick respawn
time mm-hmm you got to get to bacon a
lot of stuff yes you get to playing
cooking now for me like as I was going
through because whenever I had been
fighting a lot of I had two things that
I could make like 50 of the same recipe
mm-hmm I went to one vendor and just
baked like all of those so I'm like
already about halfway through it I
haven't even done so just find as you
like naturally playthrough because
you're gonna have if you have some time
over the next you know little banana
fish we got like nine more days so work
on playing it naturally and then
eventually like if you gotta buy some
stuff cool but for the time being you
probably all right
play normally for a while absolutely no
but yeah there were some people there
asking for a bungee holiday card and
somebody went ahead and made this one
may all your dreams and wishes for the
holidays come true nice touch yeah
pretty cool I like the look at the
engrams in there like the dreaming city
statues overall pretty cool stuff and
dreams and wishes nice tie-in to the
dreaming city and the Omkara overall
nice little uh subtle but good touch on
the card I like it exactly next week if
you guys have been enjoying me oh I
didn't actually want to ask you you
finally play a little mayhem yes very
nice get into that before you get an
Ironman er yes would yank what's the
dominant thing what are you working with
hunters me rajesh just just a few of
them ah just bleh barrage all day that's
all it like literally they've been shut
mind over a warped down like it but foot
like if to the point like but right when
I'm about to activate I came to be
sneaky I'm just like oh when that thing
sees you it's on site it is over
so yeah bleh bro that's what I get a lot
of so it is funny though some people
I've seen walking around with videos
with their Sentinel shield just walking
around to me unlike Universal Figaro
some people thrown supers at you you're
just walking around just keep going be
wrong going up I'm seeing them too but
yeah bladezz's and that's kind of thing
that annoyed me about blades because
I've been I was running to tighten on
that one just cuz I'm slowly working on
that quest that is not account based
which still pisses me off
but it's just slowly working on that and
it's just the point of I running around
in super form already activated yes you
know go to throw my hammer but if he
sees that flying he can click the super
todd have the immunity like frames or
whatever it's gonna be i say that like a
dark souls game and have the like the
immunity or the very high resistant
damage section kills because his blade
barrage is still gonna put enough damage
into me but my hammer that smashes him
in the face doesn't do anything those
little pieces are
those little back-and-forth some like
okay well I can't win that battle like I
just don't have a chance
but yeah Jimbo blade brush the shards of
fun is basically should be a little Hut
is our unstoppable with that being man
oh my god I mean as the recharge rate is
so high and shards is basically breaking
that some people are saying it's coming
back in like four or five seconds I'm
like holy crap like you're not even
talking when to supervise and all that
even see mhm oh my god I forgot about
that too much
oh that's crazy it's insane but yeah I
felt the effects and have my little
flood and quickly got right back to
regular woods cool it we're getting the
crucible went in it next after we get to
the next day a lot to say about uh some
competitive crucible we'll get it to oh
yeah I got some things to say well next
week Lord Saladin will visit the tower
for the final banner of this year you
said armor new you know emblem shader
bringing back a couple old-school guys
here to new year one weapons upgraded to
include random rolls I'm like okay so we
got two new year one weapons can you
throw like ten more into the loophole
and they stretch it it out they statute
it out they think it's like come on now
guys there's a decent amount of weapons
in there or is my man Annan and where's
my Uriel's gift give me give me some of
those to start just trickle them back in
there and be like hey on this one we're
gonna be at you know well you know five
more weapons back in loop and you know
maybe one new perk that can come on some
of these just little stuff to keep
adding and I'm not saying it's an easy
thing for them to add right but in my
mind it doesn't feel like it should be
overly that difficult the model is done
most of the perks are there yeah it's
gonna change they like the database of
how the weapon can work mm-hmm which I'm
sure I'm just like oh yeah just do this
and they're in the background going it's
gonna break the game and I'm like I'm
Terry I'm glad to see heroes burden back
I wish to be my baby like but again that
was the old meta what you know pre-shock
the SMG heroes burdens of beats that was
like my go-to in the energy squad PvP
prior to the weapons flower changes
prior to
shotguns you know really being back in
full force
so yeah I'm curious to see how that
rocks what about you I mean a hand
cannon if I can get a decent roll on it
I'd like to see how it goes it's
probably gonna feel a lot like the Duke
I think it's a slower one if I remember
correctly but I don't actually know the
stats on it yeah I think it's a 110 like
a like a Duke so for me the roll I
really want right now is probably like I
definitely need rapid hit on that hand
cannon if I can get like a rapid hit
kill clip oh man that's lethal yeah
that's what I need if we can do that you
know obviously outlook kill clip that's
good you know kind of thing but I'm
curious to see how I don't think
Harold's Parden gonna survive man I'm
fortunate not with me that's Chris
Gerber said it yet no one's using smg's
or cider
I don't even see those either I mean if
they are okay I mean when dudes is
running around with you know Shep and
all these other shotguns and it just
don't say mapping you but you know
they've got that they got that fall out
plays role you know it's just it's hard
it's hard to compete man it's hard for
SMGs to compete so I don't know what's
gonna happen with that and um and in
sidearms to be honest like they're in a
tough spot right now they really are I
was like I don't see him I look around I
get them popping up in my inventory for
drops or anything and I just keep like
these could be cool rolls but I feel
like there's no use in trying it out and
they in said they both like smg's pull
scout rifles and then sidearms like they
are they are lacking a place right now
for some way or another I'm not sure how
to fix them but whoo yeah they they need
some love in some way or another in some
way or another yeah yeah I don't know if
he can increase time to kill but
something man because that that one hit
kill potential of the shoddy from the
distances now that they're getting it's
it's it's tough you know to really even
have an SMG or a side-on compete in that
space yeah I mean SMG personally like
within that close range should
absolutely just melt your face mm-hmm I
mean that's literally what it's meant to
do it's been
losing just up close right not good that
many shots just broke and just melted
you get in the range of my SMG you are
probably not gonna make it hmm and but
it shouldn't just shoot a shotgun that's
kind of a key oh shout out to what
blackjack Ian Chad he's staying at risk
run is still good you got to put me on
bro I'm not seeing I'm not seeing the
winner in PvE all damn day long yeah VP
you gotta put me on man you know cuz I
just uh I can't see he's he's fun police
and he's doing Ted the hunter oh man
oh you're annoying I like that oh I've
seen those in here like like oh you're
like oh where do I have to not run right
now and then somebody walking around
pooping people as well I'm like all
right now I gotta play this one at range
which is where I do enjoy my hammers at
that point because then I can go smash
to tell their hunter in the face but
it's really an end oh is that you got me
set it to is just like hammers can't
beat Don blade when both are in the air
it's like yeah we're both in the air and
his wave comes at me my hammer flies
back and I lose I'm just like what the
hell why our hammer so weak yeah that's
true that's a good point
frustrating me anyway um got some new
armor what do you think of a color
scheme um probably it looks it looks
cool I like Oh Titans look we talked
about the before times still look a
little weird
they look small it looks small but there
yeah there are some people who are not a
fan of the broad shoulder Titan debut in
destiny 2 so for them I guess this is
gonna appease to them something kind of
a little bit more sleek he'd been doing
his cardio Titans been doing their
cardio for that one to get into that but
I like my warlocks he's looking cool um
Hunter's got the little crown going on
which looks fly I can dig it
um I I think I like the other two still
a little bit better but these are not
terrible I'm not saying like these are
like these are trash but this is just
why I'm at man this is uh I need this
armor I need this time and hopefully
they continue to roll with high
resilience because for whatever reason
majority of warlock armor does not have
resistance there's always mobility and
recovery so I need me some high
resilience armor
I don't know if that's their way of
basically trying to steer PV peers into
like you want to be mobile you should
have mobility arm I know I want to have
some options yep
you know it'd be nice just cuz I swear
is I mean I think you're right because
it feels like most of iron banner is
just like mobility mobility I'm like no
no no no if I go slow but I survived I'm
alright with it at least this will be
the first armor we can mod we can slide
we can have because it just sucks man I
really love the other design pieces of
the old you know All Seasons iron banner
but like you know like you you predicted
like I'm not pulling that out of the
fall with no you know without being able
to spec it would I be able to put a
super-modern it or you know grenade mod
or what-have-you
so you know to be able to use this armor
that hopefully should be higher
resilience and be able to respect is
what I want cuz I need and now fit I
might I might make that my uh my solar
outfits you know I like to have all my
subclasses have a specific theme in a
company yeah so that'll probably go to
the solar class being I just got my what
you call it out my well of radiance uh
30 see the light so that's that's the
goal for this one yeah speaking of like
solar subclass I still wish they would
allow you to just a masterwork perks
whether especially if it's the armor
there's like six different things that
can be rolled on there it's like so that
math is stupid already then let's see I
go all the way through and I have like
void on one Ark on one solar on another
and it's like what if I just want to go
straight up solar all the way down in
that master work perk role and I
actually want to spend some money there
are some some pores on it but I'm like
nope don't have the right rolls ideas oh
yeah there's there's little tweaks where
there's enough randomness in the game or
I don't think that would break things
where you're like hey let me have like
full solar resistance I mean even the
weapon perks like those I can almost see
leaving before letting us like switch
which damage resistance we have so I
agree a little bit of personal a little
bit of choice a little bit not let me
you don't have to give us all the choice
because I mean that's where people were
going for
what was the reforging of weapons or
whatever they were doing just going for
rerolls then they everybody eventually
get the gun rule yeah without wound a
seadoo ban she used to be there for
weapons week or whatever was called yeah
yeah you said you literally was stated
all day waste whatever material was and
you just keep trying to reroll that bad
boy yeah an iron banner next week also
as gaming Forte said it's gonna be
helpful giving you uh giving you up to
six forty six fifty get that boost in
there for those late levels so you got
some time are you Christmas Day oh yeah
I'll be around seven powerful drops
that's gonna be big mm-hmm listen I'll
be in the shower for today said Iron
Man's gonna be rough going up against o6
4650 guardians like I'm like six twenty
five six thirty years I'm not ready to
fight you got me he's gonna go smack me
around a little bit
yeah I didn't think about that foot tell
you right because powers back I'm the
one they complained about did I lose you
for a second or yeah you felt sounded
like you're left all of a sudden went
real quiet so yeah well I kick for a
little bit but I'm back but yeah I don't
want to get roughed up I don't to be the
you know kindergarten style yeah this
curb was like yeah it's gonna be rough
on you guys and he's like yay
she's over there like I cannot remember
the guy in the Simpsons mmm just saying
accidents floor with the rest of us so
it's gonna be getting rekt you did say
you wanted to talk about the other side
of PvP what do you got sir what
competitive crucible action has been
floating your doorstep let me transition
because I'll set it up because obviously
is gonna go into the next thing which is
the microwave Wi-Fi section for a Bungie
Security Response Team B we had to pay
in hammer so let's set that up first
right foot while this Mustang passes me
so uh Wow you know me I'm like on dancer
because they yeah if I create so man so
pretty much they say they got you know
since this weekend they're gonna do
update two point one point three they
deploy some new tools from the Security
Response team to help improve the
competitive environment of the crucible
so beginning soon players with the most
unreal
like their plays with the most
unreliable connections we receive an
in-game warning we know that colleague
connection is fluid so don't worry if
you have occasional temporary issues so
basically they're gonna receive you can
receive one of those warnings and then
there will be guys help you diagnose
your network issues and if all fails
contact your ISP if your connection does
not improve after the in-game warning
and we continue detecting negative
impact on other Guardians restriction
from PvP activities maybe apply to your
account interested if indicated
severance fixes this yeah preach you
know you read my mind on this so if a
restriction is applied to your account
you'll be unable to participate in PvP
for two weeks and if you continue to
play on an unreliable connection to harm
to experience with other players the
restriction may be extended so it's good
to see them kind of go back to this I
want your thoughts first on this
Security Response Team banhammer stuff
before I get into my competitive
discussion I mean ban hammers one thing
so I mean people's with unreliable
connections that's like I mean if you if
you got a 56k dial-up modem sorry you
probably shouldn't be playing that's
just how that works your house you
should not be played this five hundred
free hours like sorry like 100 free
hours in two hundred hours five hundred
four hours among how many hours in a
month because I'm pretty sure they maxed
it out so but yeah especially in
competitive for sure this is like it's
got to happen I mean got Apple crappy
connections whether they notice more
ddossing whether it's people are doing
subtle stuff just to make people lack I
don't know if those are even all
possible things to do but yeah I mean if
you're gonna have competitive be
something that people don't want to just
like bash their head against the wall
and be like nope
yeah that's one of those things that
it's got to be now dedicated service
what if they just did like dedicated
servers for competitive I mean quick
planning like quick plate could be like
your matchmaking you know you're however
they do it peer-to-peer and stuff like
that but I was like if you want
competitive like true rewards like you
know your let people grinding up to like
legend connections matter the drop just
what if it was just dedicated on
competitive you want incentive for
people to go play competitive I mean I
was gonna help me transition and um you
know remember when you asked me you know
how's my you know coming from console to
PC you know of the crucible how am i
doing I said alright let me settle in
let me not give you anything now I'm
settling it and all right first off
let's just get the elephant out the room
for any console guys that are coming
over right you're gonna feel strong at
first you know you're gonna be doing
your thing and quick play once you start
playing competitive consistently you're
gonna start to see the difference
because it's a level of accuracy that a
mouse and keyboard person is just gonna
have right so that's off top for us I do
notice I'm finishing high but I'm not
you know dominating like I would be in
console where you get Nino the number
one spot a little bit more frequently
don't same kind of thing so now like me
having good games like two or three and
that's fine you know what I'm noticing
though is I'm playing a lot of
competitive and the first thing I'm
noticing is that like rooms are not
filling up you don't know it could be
the player comp you know whatever play
account and that's fine but like I'm
going like 75% of the match you know in
a competitive you know for v3 and then
people are just leaving and I'm just
like are you serious right now so
they're dead goes my rank like and you
don't get any consolation prize so you
got that going on and it's just one of
those things that it's like I've been
seeing stuff like that I've been seeing
connection issues now connection issues
happens on console I'm not trying to
make this just a PC thing but you know
it's one of those things that I'm
curious now if this is coming out as a
result of that you know what I mean like
if this statement is coming out be
cuz they're seeing you know a lot of
people doing cuz I'm seeing people
floating around doing things that really
seem suspect and I'm just like okay
something's going on now again I don't
want to just blame the PC community and
stuff like that but if dudes are hacking
something's going on right now because
I'm seeing some funky stuff every once
in a while where I know I should be
getting kills and some people are
teleporting around and doing craziness
what about you see my competitive
experience is a whole bunch of not much
are you doing this way are you doing
this with randoms are you doing this
with like people you know for some
people me and scream go hard we go in
there live scream let's really put some
work in yes so we will rock now we're me
a screamer together I didn't notice it
as much well I know it's been I noticed
when I was solo queuing man the uneven
teams or you're playing against guys and
it's just like okay that's not humanly
possible you know dudes a teleporting
you're getting credit laid or you
getting shot late so there's definitely
some weirdness going on that's why I
felt the timing of this was interesting
because I definitely felt you know the
the competitive scene right now is a
little wonky right now server wise and
in other wise so it's good to see it
when they update this I know they've
talked about things like this in the
past but I really want them to crack
down on this man I really do because it
really is frustrating to be playing
competitive which I'm having a ton of
fun in but they really gotta get busy
and like you said why can't they just
have dedicated service why can't you
know especially with the amount of money
that Activision is making off of destiny
and these things it's not enough though
remember that yeah they're disappointed
yeah we're not making enough off of you
guys highly disappointed right as our
CEOs but um yeah man and I shout the WHA
blackjack it's like it's the quitters
the quitters and and they're not they're
not allowing a person to feel like how
will you play good play
so it's just like what do you do to that
man like to just get mopped after your
guy left is is frustrating I think you
don't like if somebody leaves or gets
disconnectedness maybe more than like
say if it's more than I don't know 15
seconds or something like that maybe and
that's I don't know if that's one of
those matches where people would like
disconnect or something and then they
maybe if they do if they pull the plug
like you get to disc a you're not gonna
jump back and competitive for like an
hour go do something else there's enough
a ton of stuff in this game right the
other side goes okay but like
uncompetitive like when you lose a rink
when somebody gets disconnected from
your game that sucks for you and it's
nothing you can control facts yeah you
can't leave because you get a penalty so
it should be like hey you haven't come
back it's been 30 seconds they're not
like getting back in okay this match is
null and void and draw fine maybe the
other team you give a win for but
definitely don't deduct it from the
people where they just got screwed right
and it's like you know I get it it's
competitive but I guess I'm kind of want
them to kind of revisit joining in
progress because it it's it you could do
it I've been in matches that it's been
competitive both side like oh man it's
gonna be sweaty but I'm getting into it
I'm hyped right and you know it's like
let's say you're doing competitive and
it's like survival and you know it's
going back and forth and then like I
said a guy will drop and it's just like
you're like wait a minute why I had a
big lead what's going on and then I'll
press that button and I'm looking at the
roster and I'm like oh no wonder and
I've had this happen too many times
lately BOTS like too many times like
it's been a good it's like it's forcing
me to do a three a three stack of force
that grab a screen be I rock I grab up
you because like I just don't want that
to happen is soda more as you're putting
into work and the other team just comes
back roars back just because they have
the man advantage
nothing you can do about it yeah I mean
that's especially in that numbers is
huge so and that's why somewhere they've
got to agree that it's like that I'm
dramatics the same ways like he said he
totally agrees that's why he kind of
gave up on Luna and that's why I really
haven't stepped into Luna because I
don't really have until you guys
recently been all been coming on PV up
on PC I
haven't had a hardly anybody who would
who I know consistently to play with so
for me to even jump in with randoms in
competitive sounded like a stupid task
in the first place yeah and even if I
did win crap like this would start
having to be like well screw it never
minds like so I mean if you guys will
it's like if we ever get a point where
we can actually work together on it yeah
that might be an option but then just
little stuff what if one of us gets
didn't get disconnected you guys are
like how we're trying come on stick
together but it's three versus four
we're getting kind of screwed and it's
just a connection thing and you guys
lose that would suck too so man it's
like they have to find some way if
somebody gets disconnected on the team
and don't hold it against them if the
other team sits there and they farm it
out and they win cool you put in the
time and just count the victory it's not
world ending but I was like if you if
somebody drops out and however it is you
should not lose rank for that that's
just so so poorly done or at least
alright if I'm gonna lose like you you
should have an algorithm that knows that
that team lost you know toward unfair
advantage so not saying you give me an
exotic but you gotta give me something
like you know like to see your rank go
down when you had you have no control
over it and like there should be some
level of a reward system to be like okay
or just the penalty is lessened right
how about that how about this should be
an algorithm at end of match if it
wasn't a 4v4 finish yeah there should be
a lesson penalty for you you got a
reward the guy that stood there and just
took that beaten I should be honestly it
should be one of those where it's just
like you know what am I thinking of just
in quick play or something or if you
join a match in progress you're not
gonna lose your streak if you have a
crowd if you have a crappy situation
somebody just gets disconnected it's not
a full set of four that finishes that
group or there's a point you can be like
or or all four people in here for the
whole time you know disconnecting comes
back for like two rounds later there's a
point where it's like they're not in the
match for you know a relatively equal
amount of time like more than a minute
or something like that then yeah you're
not gonna lose streak you're not gonna
lose rank the other team can win cool
but don't deduct I mean it's hard enough
to make the grind random matches like
that should not just like
screw up us because then if you screw up
your streak you lose one and then you're
out losing streak for a couple it's like
it's just that it starts to snowball and
again I just want to know the philosophy
behind eliminating join in progress in
competitive you have it in quit played
why is that such a moral violation you
know I'm saying if someone dropped
that's an unfair advantage so let's make
it fair
let's get someone back in me I just
don't understand how they look unless
it's some you know obviously I'm not a
program unless it's some exploit thing
that they're worrying about you know say
I just can't I just don't understand
yeah I actually should do what said
Fred's been there he's been trying to do
his three matches a week to get the
bonus points at least to secure that
fabled rank he's like I don't know if
that'll help that I should do honestly
yeah just some matches a week just to
get the bonus so I mean that's I think
that'll help but it's just and that is
you know a nice thing for those who do
play you get a little bonus in there but
really like if you get dropped if it's
not a full team at the end it it should
read that information in the moment be
like okay losing team you got hosed
whatever reason it was you don't have a
full team at the end fine I mean and
that's one point where but it's like in
turn somebody gets disconnected they
can't just be like oh we're about to
lose I'm gonna disconnect so I don't
lose my rank so I mean that's kind of
the balance between those two where
they've got lines because if somebody
just like well pull the ethernet cord
and then you're done but you know is
your rank but then if you have a
disconnection like you know if say you
do that more than once then you're kind
of done like it's got a keep some
tracking in there and that's again I
don't know where that balance lies back
and forth okay again not to hop too much
but so I'm just trying to understand
what you and game before tell you saying
you know so that the pot should so what
they're saying is what you guys are
saying is that most they they're
preventing it for that if someone is
about to lose and then they disconnect
that they don't get you know their their
their rank go down right is that yeah
yeah yeah it's kind of their way to
cheat the system
so okay wiki they dig just kind of have
a pad of tools in place right it
shouldn't matter to like the minute you
know do if you get dropped you get
dropped like you're gonna you gotta get
a pound
all right I don't know how else to put
it like they should have a system in
place I mean I don't know man I really
still think that it's a situation that
needs to be addressed
better than how it is now USA my
suggestion is hey you you get you get
pumped you get yo that's that's on you
who you know it is what it is you know
saying yank gotta go down that's just
how I feel about it you tell me if I get
a brain of mass Buffalo err excuse the
language sorry random Buffalo here
that's my fault
well if you didn't pay the power bill
this month that's your running not me
that's the trouble with the bill this
wolf
that's not mean that's kind of thing
it's like if you if it's a consistent
thing on your account right I mean that
can be one worry if you get dropped and
they notice like hey it's a consistent
Megan that's somebody doing that it's
like that's where you get that warning
and if you're like it's like dude
literally have numbers be like losing it
it of match disconnects like in the last
like 60 seconds of the match like
multiple times that's something that
they could probably just check on game
records pretty quick if I get
disconnected I shouldn't get screwed
because of one random error sometime
even if I jump back in then stay in so
that's why I was like the person who
loses its he made I don't think like you
know then your games basically null and
void you're not gonna lose anything but
you're not gonna change anything right
maintain points won't go down but you're
not gonna have that and you're probably
not gonna win a disadvantage yeah but if
the other team sticks out out of wins
it's one more win in their belt it's not
gonna hurt anything let them have it
right right and actually I like what you
just said because what they should do is
just that which is the team who loses
the person due to disconnect right or
whatever well then I see what you say
any other way people might try to milk
it that way if I see what you got to say
because what dudes are gonna do is old
man are streets gonna lose you'll jump
out you know say but that's just that
one person I kind of see what you guys
are doing but man I still want joint in
progress
what's it let's see well but I think
ultimately I like where they're going
with this Security Response Team thing
and um you know for pee
abusing the system or just your
connection is unreliable like you know
they need to be some type of you know
sheriff system going on with that so at
least I like that and I want to bring up
no I mean it's definitely something that
he's talked about and what's the thing
that usually keeps people that
alternative alternative thing to do BBB
so yeah I mean but grinds in there for
like Lunas howl or not forgotten I mean
I haven't even thought about those
hardly I should but for me it always
seems like don't have that many play
with now I've got a few just good so
what I do but you know let's say you do
that that's fine I'll drag you through a
ninth I'll drag you through whatever but
help me you backpack me in that
competitive manner of give up get my
weapons together slowly but surely
slowly but loadouts getting together
it's getting getting PvP ready so I'm
almost there almost it's a couple more
super Minds here and then a couple more
exhausts two haven't got any exotics yet
but as far as armor you know that I
really want so I think transverses
haven't gotten Athenians yet hell dude
last night I don't even know what was
happening a text incognito last night as
it was going down I was just playing
along going through some dreaming city
stuff doing some usual drops and then
all of a sudden I was like hey I was in
that did the what was it the bounty for
the Bay of drowning wishes or whatever
it's just a loss sector and go do the
loss Decker I go in there random dude
that I'm like running up on last final
guy I shoot BAM Cerberus plus one pops
up on the screen where the hell'd that
come from so I get that and then what
what did I do
it was not long after I went like loaded
back to the landing zone and then I did
hold on I got a look at the text because
then it was the one that kind of just
was amazing for me I remember what you
got I just wouldn't know what you did oh
and then yeah so it was I was literally
like I had the weekly bounty for Ava
Levante in my inventory and I was just
sitting there I was like I'm gonna go
over to Petra and bake like 4 or 5
things so I baked like four things and I
finished up the weekly bonus let's see
what I get from this geomatics
stabilisers I was like oh my god oh I am
so jealous drunk
I'm gonna go start having some more
funny gambits with those things you
ain't cut by two with the damn geomat I
was politics in less than 10 minutes I
mean it feels like it's been a while
since I've got one but I was like two
and that long I was like dude yeah I
think it was like making up for
something there cuz I was like I have
not seen one in a bit but I just got to
real close together mmm that was a
little nuts yeah those little moments
like that though see like if it does
take me that long to get exotics and
then to go back to back and I get stuff
like that I'm like hello hello like
Cerberus one I'm not like not really
thinking it's gonna be amazing it's just
kind of like a spread weird-ass gun but
Geo mags I know what those do with chaos
reach so Oh beast yeah those are gonna
be nuts
so scream good morning thank you for
joining us what is up sir Oh
see ya that was a random little tangent
that happened to me but yeah seriously
mmhmm yeah that was crazy I was just
like I was texting you like dude leave
me alone I was like dude another what
does happen you're like gonna like go
talk to eat or what anyone gets geo mags
and the ones that get for what I guess
me and my fearless is geo mags Phoenix
Protocol got that recently Oh
- right
yeah I'm like oh like I've never even
stiffed those that'll castle dot nothing
sir
let's see man but again the only thing
that's saving me is the orange Jesus has
blessed me with on the Lord which I will
say like for you and a random drop to
have Thunder Lord as early as you did
because you didn't make it through the
quests you don't get a whole lot of
complaining honestly cuz when you say
like that gun will carry you through to
the end of time for a while alright now
it's been carrying me
that is what saving me literally but at
the same time it's like um like I said
I've been getting weapons but I'm just
not getting armor that's what yeah I
understand mm so hopefully I'll be
waiting for a certain someone am their
video
hey you know hour and a half I'm gonna
get it up so don't worry waiting baby
waiting yeah don't think anything crazy
is gonna be happening but it'll be there
and I need transverses we got
transverses Luna faction or from a wall
or I need armed what you call it
Nazareth sin those are all three those
are key to my game oh I could use a
little arm I'm a chorus girl to die
transversal huh just disappointing oh
let me let me tell you people are they
sleep on that in PvP it is so important
to not have the reload option to not
worry about reloading your weapons like
especially you're running around with
heavy you know you got you running
around with a war cloth or cliff or
whatever or just two shotguns in general
because I the way I run my build is I'll
use the what is a discover injure in the
reserve perks so picking up more per
brick but you know you still got switch
over and reload it to have that on Stowe
just for gonna man you it is a very very
underrated exotic and I'm saying so yeah
man so yeah shout the fort say yes I'm
gonna just want one character right now
for it to your PC mm-hmm yes if I just
have to let everybody know you say you
haven't all you have like every
character on xbox this is your first one
on PC it's good it's a grunt I mean you
you focused on one right now
now I mean granted if you I mean time is
always a precious thing well I was gonna
say if you had to to bounce ca3 was a
lot but to to bounce is a way like if
you get those weapons up that person
will ramp up quicker and then you kind
of like teeter-totter back and forth
like helping each one go up so two is
actually a good thing to do fast I'm so
jealous of Chris Korell Eaton Forte
right now I've never even sniffed
protocol and what's the other walk when
I never see the one with Mother Earth
old oh I need a shout the cool guys got
a good video on that and the one the
other one that it's like a shaman kind
of a chess piece that makes all the
precision kills the chromatic fire or
something
CDs man no geomet like they will not
give me any forsaken warlock armor is
jobbing that's right over continue oh
they go war blackjack got thunder lord
for the first time yesterday
so just a random drop now nice lose well
black oh that's a little black when I
got him so he's just trolling people now
I guess you can put away your tractor
cannon and tether for Lowell and
actually a fun going on the offensive as
opposed to picking taking people off all
day long sir woo yeah it's like I saw
Geo mags and when you run around you
handle like these little three like
light up like things on your feet looks
like I'm running around in Tron boots it
looks hilarious
what do you light up it's like this
weird little three glowing three I can't
tell if it's on the back of the boot or
the bottom but either way when I'm
running the way the feet kick up I see
this like three line thing I was running
around Sowers like I like I have Tron
boots on I like Tron ski boots like they
just look weird they look fun look they
look bigger and bulkier on warlock feet
yes delicate feet but I feel like pick
up some oomph to him so yo shout out to
the hunter I saw in the tower he had him
on I had to take a picture he was one of
the flyest flies warlocks excuse me
first were like that I've ever see he
had like the raid chest did geo magadh
awning adorning helmet but he had like a
white shader and the bags was silver his
outfit was late I was like damn you
looking kind of clean and I had to stop
and look at us like tell you look kind
of clean in the towel boy so I forgot
was shaded it's like a white and silver
he it was like the boy was glowing I was
like damn that's kind of how I can't get
those geobags red I've already got my
outfit planned in my head when I get up
here for Black Jacks it's like yeah I
saw that hunter with those geo magazines
like you crossing character streams now
what are you doing sorry about that he's
confused I was confused I was his aura
had me will forgive you this time gotta
keep in check mmhmm yeah
generally a couple more things on the 12
just talking about the new forge
there's some things that are known
issues they're still working on and then
they wrap up with if you guys have not
seen this little gambit etiquette video
it's great it's short it's sweetness
hilarious hmm so if you have not seen
this one it's kind of like an old-school
southern hospitality
it's
kind of awesome in a great way so if you
guys go to Bungie check out the 12 check
out the movie the weeks again but one
it's just a really hilarious little
video and just basic things again but
that we all should be doing but it's
just the way it's presented it reminds
me of like an old school like because
she's like you know got the southern
dress it's like from the fifties I got
the pearl necklace and she's sitting at
home and just saying get your get your
act together it's just kind of great
outs pretty good yeah they just kind of
wrap up basically saying dylaney is out
of town he's got his vacation going on
so cosmos got us covered
yeah you guys will notice the boys ik in
the top of the header so Elliot gray has
been basically creating all these images
and this is his last Wobblies he moves
on to a different role so the one at the
very very top up here this is all I
don't know if it's all the table or what
he's been doing for I mean that's so
much that he's put together there it's
really really cool so like held out like
if they can make that a wallpaper that'd
be awesome
yeah stabby late that one's pretty sick
so but yeah it's been a great year the
updates they updated the game 29 times
in 2018 oh it's a Brad I mean it's every
other week yeah that's impressive and we
want to Aidan sweet we complained about
a case at the very beginning when we
first started doing flashpoint like that
is something we have to give them credit
they've been they've been very much
faster very much more transparent
yeah so we're Blackjacks like the very
talk about the Oracle thing I love how
you just suddenly say the Oracle thing
oh yeah we talked about
oh yeah we're towards the in giant
spoilers if you guys haven't seen it
when you go to the Oracle Aldrin is a
guardian and the ramifications of that
are crazy and insane we talked about it
earlier in the podcast though so yes it
is it is nuts but honestly like they the
future looks pretty good right now so
we've got the calendar of last word
coming up I don't know how long that
quest is gonna be and I'm hoping since
I'm on PC maybe I can actually enjoy
that gun cuz on console I was terrible
yeah it was so terrible with that gun
yeah I was decent don't last word I mean
I'm curious to see you know the
iteration it comes back and now cuz
there
I believe there is gonna be some change
uh based on where the probably the main
perk is coming back but um I believe
there's another perk as well so based on
I guess the data mine shot the unknown
playing something up on it but uh yeah
man I'm curious to see how it works in
this current meta has its you know that
thing dominated the older Metis you know
that was a very strong strong so I'm
looking forward to see see what it do
you know now because it's got it's got a
lot of competitions into space curious
about the range on it as well the
hipfire shooting there's a lot of
questions but you know I mean they're
definitely gonna give it to treatment so
I'm excited that gun has tremendous lore
oh yeah I'm it's definitely one of the
cooler guns that and thorn both kind of
getting those in there just kind of cool
to see them take a gun like that and
actually give it the lore that it
deserves yeah and I just wish that
they'd not just be like hey this guns
back in the game you're gonna bring it
back like give it the love that some of
these deserve or make some up for it
because the quest that we get the story
at least gives a little more weight when
we get those exotics not like here's a
random here's a random gun like those
don't have the same feel so it's like
when these things have stories and
quests and stuff I do enjoy those so
that's actually pretty cool but niobe
labs on the h8 can't talk and then at
the 20 yep and then the 29th will be
last word I don't think there's anything
in between those two is there mmm I feel
like there's something in between those
two but I gotta try and crimson will be
February
oh here's the road ahead I can look so
we've got the Izanami forward now be
labs on the 8th the quests on the 29th
and February 5th will be crimson base a
week later January 8th three weeks you
got the quest that another week you got
crimson days and that'll pretty much
wrap up most of the content for black
armor and then probably come March it
starts the world season The Drifter
March to May will you write right into
that steady dripping like I said the way
they're movin looks like they might you
also include you know some secrets and
stuff maybe in between so you know it's
it's a different way of
when things but I'm getting in pocket
I'm getting in with the swing of it
we'll see how it goes
yeah also around that time frame I'm in
crimson days February 5th February 22nd
anthem oh yeah that yeah yeah man I want
to talk about certain things but
unfortunately I cannot no but I mean
just are you excited for it though
that's the bigger question yeah and
let's just say you know they are coming
so my destiny bredrin
Bungie they better start preparing and
like I think I said this maybe last
flashpoint you know this might be a time
to bring trials back you might need to
do things that the community really was
because anthem is coming yeah I've had a
lot of time on it so um you know if the
competition is fierce you know in the
space you know we got we still got
division coming you know that kind of
thing so again at the end of the day all
this is good for us as gamers you know
this hopefully pushes these companies to
um you know to compete and to give us
better content and yeah I'm dying to see
how they react for that and at that
that's my prediction
I have a I'm gonna say it now my
prediction for 2019 is that around the
anthem release window Bungie will do
trials I think trials comes back right
around during that time of what is it
that believe that should be right around
season in The Drifter right or nope yeah
season the drift that we gonna get trial
because they're going to need to do
something that is beloved that gets the
base round up what the sir bounties
aren't enough no they glad to do
something because yeah man at least in
the PvE space whoo like I said anthems
come
and it was covered cannot wait you know
for nbh break and I can get more deeper
for those who have questions but yeah I
mean that's gonna be the evolution of
gambit couple exotic quests of course
the basic stuff the new weapons in gear
for Joker's wild
and then zur bounties and another exotic
quest so I mean that one definitely
seems to be like the low key one what I
mean you need to really have you have
anthem you have division to like three
weeks later because it's on the 15th of
March yeah so three weeks two giant
games coming out two big ones a sequel
one's a pretty direct third-person
competitor kind of fitting in between
both of these it's a third-person space
magic one mm so I mean you've got a lot
of stuff to consider that is gonna be
pulling at the strings of people who are
like oh I play destiny but this is kind
of my thing
wait there's looter shooters to come out
some people are gonna try one some
people are gonna try another some people
are gonna try both and oh my god where
do I find destiny wait that one's
probably gonna set on the backburner
and that's still why I think the ones
who love like you know that's the gambit
cool evolution of that still a little
bit of a grind in there but again it's
like that season of like the summer
whatever that's gonna be a number of
shadow do you know the bad things called
that's their points of try and bring us
back in cuz that's gonna have the Ray
that's gonna have the other stuff to try
and get us ready for the fall and we'll
know more about what's hopefully coming
with September maybe and that's kind of
a ramp up to get us back you know I
still think March to May honestly is
gonna be a down time and my guess is
trials would probably be a little later
to get people hyped because I think they
almost probably have to they have to
know people are gonna step away mm-hmm
like I know I'm gonna go play some
anthem just because it looks really cool
it looks fun it's got a lot of PvE
content which is literally exactly what
I do mm-hmm whether it's solo or groups
or whatever it's like it literally is
something I've got a try Division two as
well
I played Division one that was one of
the first things I did on my channel yes
oh really I like that destiny to our
destiny one word I started with destiny
slow grinding a little baby build stuff
like that and then division was not far
away so I literally started shortly
thereafter with like a division giveaway
when I was like
less than 100 subscribers mm-hmm yeah
shout out to all you guys now I'm like
twelve hundred subs away from 30,000 you
guys awesome guys
mmm-hmm that's been a crazy crazy time
but yeah my guess is I don't think
trials is coming at the start of March
so yeah is a kind of 2019 timing
situation that'll be I'm buying you a
drink or dinner you're buying me a drink
or dinner come Guardium con trials being
no here's the key and we got people live
and watching is it with the lunch of
season with the derivative the trial
starts put me on the spot I mean so I
yeah you just said be like hey I'm
calling it now
I'm cold you know like you're gonna
disqualify me if it comes during season
two The Drifter but lightning looks like
May 31st yeah that doesn't count dude
it's gotta be March I said season to the
drift I've got to be a specific time
with season you're saying it's a call
the gun of these games coming they gotta
come with all their stops that is
literally March when anthems already
gonna be out in Division two is gonna be
in the 15th the people are like
knee-deep in the middle of both of those
games nearly hey April 25th or a
luncheon trials people like I don't care
like I put my convictions to the test so
season the Drifters launch is going to
basically in that first month first
couple weeks before what before April
let's just say that that's fair before
April I said here's the thing now let me
ask you this what if they announce it
right at the beginning when did they say
hey it's gonna come you know April such
as such but they had doubts it right
it's easy Jim does that count I think
that we're getting now we're getting
late I my my bet on this one would be
that it does not launch before March
31st okay that's I mean that's what I
want to say so I will take I'm gonna put
my convictions to the test I feel that
at that point it'll be march anthem
comes out when February
22nd 22nd it'll be out in a while people
will be excited but she's gonna have to
do something that's how I feel I feel
buns gonna hat and they cannot afford
the way the only way they if they
couldn't wait is if to your defense they
say is your hey still not ready but that
would be you know how long has it been
going now oh my god Ben
when was trials around I can't even
remember now even travels less trials
before forsaken so I mean it would have
been September in so yeah so before
forsaking trousers around so that's a
long time for it to be gone so I yeah
I'm gonna I'm you know what I'll tell
you I'll take the back whether it be
would do the drink we do dinner whatever
we before God Akane will be on one of us
we have trials bet you know what we're
out there and yeah I'm with it man I'll
put put it all on a lot yeah
all right before March 31st March 31st
mm-hmm and see this is one of those were
I don't mind because if I lose yes what
a lot of people are happier I take these
bits for the good of the people because
if I lose then you guys are happy if I
win well we're all unhappy except me
facts
I like the Midtown like the thought
process he was teasing me he's like
semantics listen I gotta know what I'm
getting into sometimes but now I'm doing
it I'm doing it bad yeah I think they
they've got to do something man they've
got at Wendy's division launch what's
divisions release date March 20 March 15
oh you've got that weeks they could have
to heavy hitter and division has been
the thorn and they sad when division
first launched that means they will have
no mindshare for a little bit you know
that the Harcourt I mean the casual
destiny community is going to play those
games they are going to me too only I'm
definitely betting you buddy yeah my
meal was already I better visualize what
I want from you what drink I want what's
your preference there what's your meal a
chaser steak
okay I need quick question what is your
a steak of choice I'm you think well
you're in a steakhouse they got all
the options on the table what do you
pick we could do a New York Strip we
keep in New York no but what's your
favorite that's what I'm literally
asking like everything right like I'm
such a snake feed okay no but I'm just
saying like if you can say here's a
strip here's a fillet here's a ribeye
here's a t-bone
rib eyes is definitely up there t-bone
is up there um-hmm I'm just a FIFA steak
bro I just want it on you when you
scream get out of here with that flank
steak you what are you doing to me no
it's a bone-in rib eye that's what you
do
yeah rip i like rib eye I like what
about everybody go to a fight like go to
a damn good steak house get like a three
or four week wet or dry depending on the
restaurant they're both pretty good like
three or four week dry aged medium-rare
bone-in ribeye you're know oh yeah like
trust me if I'm gonna do steak yeah I
see I was like your bougie with the
things I don't know I need to specific I
need the cut I need that right yeah we
get off the podcast 20 people have bacon
and eggs for what tasteless of a robot
oh thanks for show support three boxes
44 covered over yeah oh yeah he said a
rib eye medium rare for him my boy ice
cream is over there talking that flank
yeah I respect that
I respect the flank don't let him don't
let him just like shame you all right
flank is still good we do that you know
it has a purpose but that's not like I
want a steak that's like I want some
fajitas oh that's not flake flake no no
you know we he to me can you be coke
damn tasty but you said that little heat
a flank steak next to a bone-in ribeye
it's just like what the hell are you
doing screams you gotta get a mate come
before you right now he come for us
[Music]
this would be fun babe we got we got to
get scream out there I'm trying to talk
them into come to garner you got yeah
that'd be fun the war black so if you
guys aren't steak fans so on the other
side safe you're in a nice place if you
do go fish do you go do you have a good
fish you like um not the biggest fish to
be honestly I'm just I'm like biting
some and I ain't I ain't too complex
dear you know I'm more of a shrimp
lobster kind of guy like shrimp
especially so that that's like my bag as
far as when it comes to seafood but like
meat potatoes steak that oh let's go
that's all me right there being matthäus
yeah well you know mm-hmm Salmons
getting stuff yeah really well cooked
salmon always enjoy my favorite even
though I know I proba [ __ ] needed that
much it's not that bad for me it's
actually just not a really a reliable
fish is Chilean sea bass mmm that is my
favorite fish if I can do that
I'll do like miso salmon glazed
marinating and that'll do but like broil
it for a little bit and then I've
usually made a meal of like kind of
grilled asparagus and then like hibachi
style homemade fried rice do that for
like me and my wife that's a damn good
meal really enjoy that one you doing it
up man this is chef the boss's talk I
figured that's why you you're the chef
that's right I like food man yeah and by
the way thank God I am a kickboxing
instructor because it's a balance in
there I'm not like a lean mean
kickboxing instructor I could be thinner
but I'm glad I workout as much as I do
because I love as well so that's gonna
check that war blackjack was just like
not feeling so much on the steak I was
like what's your preference he's like
you guys do a steak house he'll go sushi
I'm like man sushi is a thing like if
done well and everything my brother's
out there listening right now sushi like
in from a really really good sushi chef
and it's never really been my thing but
man like sushi can be amazing I've done
well so yeah if you guys are sushi
lovers
about the yoga see that's what I'm
talking about you got me it's the
cheesecakes he got see I forget
that stuff you want my cheesecake that I
got done making yeah yeah you guys go
check my Twitter feed there's a lemon
blueberry cheesecake floating out there
so Oh
cheesecake is like that is my crack like
like I'm addicted to that like it is so
good when I seen this man cooking I'm
like yo you gonna have to chef me one of
those man steak and then the cheesecake
to finish it off I'm good life is good
oh yeah you just Benz will just lay down
on that couch with that food baby
cuz you're done after stacking
cheesecake you know you got like three
rolls some butter on the side mm-hmm
souther Kobe's he's got to get that
workout every day before I play D to
escape yeah I feel you bro you're saving
if me and this man we don't hit the gym
will be fatties cuz the way we eat and
what we like forget about it
Max is over here saying Jesus I want
some pancakes right now I'm like dude I
want to go to IHOP I'm just destroyed
they don't even make my favorite in
Morris the cinah stack has the cinnamon
because I had like the cinnamon roll
glaze had like the actual like cream
cheese kind of frosting drizzled over
yeah I don't I don't put touch any syrup
or anything on Joe's just Cinna stacks
straight up you go nice you have to
change name to a food podcast at this
rate hungry guardians there we go the
hungry guardians we doing our own
daunting event the dawning of my need to
work out more the dawning for my new
year's resolution to stop eating go on
here it's gonna get ridiculous oh oh
this is a great great Chevy Bonta is
gonna have another playlist on this
channel it's like yeah it's like destiny
guides we got anthem we got division -
so look at cooking what is this
seriously I would pro my god I'm just
picturing like my not fall Bob Ross
voice what we're gonna do we're gonna
put some flour here some pretty little
flowers make a push over here in the
corner like oh my god
oh it would be great
you guys are awesome since why it's like
the name may change but we're still
gonna be here with you guys so see
flashpoint you see whatever their name
pops up and again well I'm gonna have
the link up on my channel I'm gonna have
you guys can hit us up on Twitter
anything you guys got for just used four
names is good and if you say hungry
Guardians most people won't know what
the hell we're talking about they're
like are you guys like cooking in
destiny are you guys using that little
table fire in a marshmallow what's
happening so yeah it's been awesome this
morning guys I think I'm probably filled
you're here with enough food so if
you're not hungry now you will be
shortly ah so yeah breakfast is probably
an order or lunch for some of you guys
depending on where you're at it's going
down while watching a soul 100k
nightfall and this is how you start with
this cheesecake you got me over there
killing me so oh my god go you'll fire a
bit yeah it's like you your scrubber
subscribe to my channel here like how
nightfall solo send a channel or a send
a challenge oh we got the one about
ending the week lemon blueberry
cheesecake what is that the same I would
honestly have to do another channel I
would have to be doing like a pontiff's
like chef guides or something goofy like
that because I couldn't have it in my
destiny feed people would just lose
their mind ended started on a question
of know what the new name but honestly
and then it always says we love to have
fun with you guys so thank you it's been
awesome I know some you guys always
trickle in later so if you guys have not
followed on twitch or subscribe to
YouTube on either both Twitter twitch
YouTube follow us everywhere mm-hmm a
cheesecake challenge can you fit can you
finish the whole cheesecake in one day
absolutely I'm green man dude ah if you
pick up one of my cheesecakes it's
literally like five pounds man throw out
you know apple pie you know cheesecake
or was it like I have a sweet tooth
that is mine oh I do too believe me but
I was like there's a point where it's
like it's my it stuff like cheesecake it
if you get a thick cheesecake it gets
rough man there's a lot in there all
about the pacing throughout the day
she's got a pace just go around just a
bite constantly
now you by the time you get to about
eleven o'clock and not be like oh okay
four bytes to go it's gonna be a
struggle if that's all you've had all
day you are not going to feel good
living on like dairy sugar milk egg form
there's gonna be your proteins coming
from some sugar but yeah you would not
feel wonderful in a day that's a long
tie
give me an hour an out two pouty to max
a girl connects a guardian go go to
Cheesecake Factory by yourself two full
cheesecakes and then let me see some
throughout the day pictures well we love
food we love gaming you guys are awesome
so we had a lot of fun but wrapping up
on two hours here probably a good place
to wrap it up so shall we shall we in
this thing last last one or 2018 and
when we come back dizzy you missed the
whole thing she's like yeah we're
wrapping up 2018 we'll try probably
around that timeframe of unless there's
something crazy that happens we'll
probably come back after that first tois
but niobe labs and things so it'll be
probably two weeks off cuz you got New
Year's I'm unless we just feel like
really doing something on the 4th
something cool is going on but likely
the 11th if it's sooner it's sooner just
stay tuned mm-hmm
that'll just give a couple weeks just
kind of mix things up and things like
that so but that'll definitely have a
lot to talk about come niobe labs and
whatever that new forges give us some
time to grind up and get into this new
forge as well yes sir yes sir man yeah
been looking forward to it you know like
I said you take a little time off
looking at that time period for that you
know as far as me you already know doing
out shows now if you're ready oh for
actually before I chose first of all
shout to ball chats you know because you
guys give us energy
you definitely guys definitely give us
energy we love doing this this thing
started off as a passion project and
regardless to whatever the name becomes
you know we definitely could not do this
without you guys you know the energy the
the actual you know the nice comments
and just to see the growth on it slowly
has really been tremendous
obviously iron law podcast very proud
you know saying the year we had he
botches super proud of the
he's had and just to see people learn
its content and just enjoy those guides
and the things that he does so one thing
we definitely want to super super shout
you guys out and like I said just take a
small break we'll be back on Twitter you
already know it's me at Lourdes Cognito
you know an iron law podcast you can
follow that as well the island podcast
will be back Sunday January 6th you know
I'm saying so then we'll have that
Sunday and then 10th flashpoint comes
right back or whatever the new name a
flash point will be so I'll probably put
a Twitter a tweet out on Isle P Twitter
just to kind of get the ball rolling you
guys can make suggestions and you know
we can take we probably me and maybe
bouncers to sit down and try to
culminate all the different choices
until we get something that we feel fits
so that's what yeah and shout out
whoever got a subscription on my channel
didn't even see it come first so thank
you for that by the way those were
always very appreciated I was looking
down at my numbers I'm like that's
higher than we started whoever it was
thank you guys but yeah I mean on both
yeah follow our Twitter's I'll be
putting out polls as well we'll look
through all that stuff get our changes
kind of going and just see if we can
kinda make it a little bit more of our
own just because apparently flashpoint
is little less unique than we were
hoping for but still got the point
across all in all guys it's been a hell
of a year I want to thank all you guys
for just being with us on the journey
some of the new friends we've got some
new faces and chat and shout out to
Cognito coming to PC man who's like I am
consul for life see a council because I
told you I was like dude as soon as you
get and you told yourself to and you
know that you're like man I don't I
don't want to get on there I'm afraid
and and you knew it
you called it it's just great that it's
there hey I'm just happy we can play
together now that's one of the best
things about it you know cuz it's like
as long as I've known you and not being
able to play Dancing with you as much as
we talk destiny was kind of killing me
because obviously we're on you know
different consoles right the first time
and then you know you jump to PC I
wasn't ready ahead and then you know it
all just came together so trust me I
knew like you said it was one of those
things that I it was so superior that I
was like there
stay away cuz I know the minute I see it
I'm gonna want it now and I wasn't ready
but now everything came together didn't
rig everything better for the podcast
and yeah I'm not going back out in here
so Yakko family of our battlenet is a
little Cognito number 12:30
so just says yeah what no but a
shout-out to your chairman thank you for
the love I really appreciate it man
happy holidays you guys and Merry
Christmas New Year's but finisher gosh
I'm sorry yeah no that's pretty much it
as well just saying you guys are awesome
enjoy if you're traveling be safe we
wouldn't be here where we are without
you guys all the support in twitch in
YouTube and Twitter just everything has
been growing like crazy
and it's been humbling online because
this is something started as a hobby
have fun doing it and just like the
little guys I mean what like just
sometimes it's a little luck in the
right place at the right time but I mean
just you guys coming back consistently
that's not luck that's you guys so thank
you very very much for this so all you
guys on both sides scream Chris Cobra
Jim all you guys dizzy sleeping through
the whole damn podcast good job say all
you guys over there guests this morning
are awesome sin and then mine as well
don't forget you guys whoever subbed and
I missed it I am sorry I totally screwed
up that one it's probably foot no max
Guardian Forte may have done it yep you
got me said Fred all you guys I see you
guys in chat I'll pop on for a random
Sunday stream I had one of my best
dreams when I just popped on for a
Sunday and it was doing shatter thrown
it I had 40 people in there with me I
said awesome guys like literally lately
it's just been it's been a lot of fun
still doing other stuff but you guys
just make this part of our days like
some of the best it's awesome so enough
enough blushing aside and then go wrap
it up here but you guys can tell we're
thankful for you guys and just thankful
to be sitting where we are enjoying an
awesome game more craziness continues
and we will be with you guys every step
of the way
and if our podcast turns into be like
hey we played destiny but dude I got to
talk about anthem for like 30 minutes
it may happen yes those games may come
out we're gonna talk about them cuz when
I get in the plane and that that demo
that's open or the VIP demo and we
preorder it's like there may be some
discussions that happen so that
hopefully you guys are on board with
that because while destiny is our
main focus if we're playing something
just as much as destiny it's gonna have
to get talked about absolutely you know
it all right guys well follow us
everywhere send the send the love to us
and send some ideas think on it even if
you're just sitting at home later and
you're like ha Tim tweet us or just
write it down and send it later
somewhere but yeah send us some name
ideas and we'll see if we can make it
happen
but I think we'll wrap it up there on
Mayan it's avant is everywhere it's easy
it's unique it's a little off but you
know where to find me and then for you
sir
yep at Lord cogito you already know at
Twitter and I've seen a battlenet is
Lord kognito number 12 13 and at iron
Lord podcast as well to catch it what
we're doing a lot of stuff cooking and I
guess a really proud of what both we any
bonds are doing and we got a lot more to
share for 2019 so happy holidays
everyone please enjoy be safe every time
see ya peace ho ho ho